I can actually go buy a Samsung
Galaxy gear 360 camera so I'm gonna go
do that maybe it 4-3 hopefully maybe not
probably not
all right so I'm trying to find
Carmichael right now he lost his keys
like all of them his car is apartment
the studio God poor guy find him
hopefully he's down here somewhere
kinda empty so far Bank I was classic I
tell you in front of a hotel oh I've
been waiting so long me every single
detective Archie
I did from
come on brown
taking a picture with you just you have
to keep smiling lost your keys did you
find them didn't find my keys yet
you think you might be able to find I
got a hold of the uber driver Oh next
but he's at the dentist he does have my
keys oh sweet my goal is to find that
Samsung gear 360 camera I must get it
anna has a lot to live up to not only
does he have a reputation of being a cat
steve-o also has a crush
steve-o
three
Mike and I were battling and I actually
dealt the real damage lit up take your
hand away yeah casualties of war God
Danny got him oh my god
friend or an animal its ruthless it
would have happened if you were wearing
a helmet what did you just get oh we got
back from the dentist uh we'd have to
spend like 200 bucks to get new ones now
last night was crazy so I wasn't able to
do it yesterday but today my goal is to
go get that 360 camera my name is mom
bloody Michael I'm from Australia
Michael Shanks yeah he makes some of my
favorite content on YouTube so it's
great oh thank you very much well
likewise I'm sorry no you see when these
cameras before it's fascinated is you
know oh oh hang out with my friend Gavin
you might have heard of him he does a
bunch of slow stuff pitch my idea to
Gavin last night and he was all game so
maybe we'll be collabing here soon
we're doing a lot of walking my feet
hurt
VidCon was a success although I ended up
buying this on my own all our patrons
are important to us but one in
particular Adam J Tilly would like to
give a quick shout-out this month one of
our best supporters on patreon a
longtime fan of our work should check
out his YouTube channel if you're
interested in what he does makes games a
little sortes youtube.com slash Adam J
Tilly
thanks VidCon is officially over but
before I left I had to do one thing yep